we've heard all five nominated songs now
let's get on to the winner uh wait a
minute Bert no small talk between us
I'll talk to you later
at home at home we won't talk we'll just
go to bed and watch Joan Blondell in the
gold diggers of 1937 hey is that hot
again tonight
well the nominations for best songs are
for all we know from the film lovers and
other strangers with music by Fred
Carlin lyrics by Rob Wilson and Arthur
Jones pieces of Dreams from the film
pieces of dreams with music by Michel
Legrand and lyrics by Allen and Marilyn
Bergman thank you very much from the
film screwed with music and listen
lyrics art by Leslie with us till love
touches your life from the film madrone
with music by resort aloni and lyrics by
arthur hamilton whistling away the dark
from the film darling Lily music by
Henry Mancini lyrics by Johnny Mercer
the winner is I think it's appropriate
Bert read their window okay the winners
are fit Carlin Rob Wilson Arthur Jones
for all we know
thank you
I would not bring prepared for this I
would just like to thank not only Rob
lawyer but of course Fred Carling for
the wonderful music and most of all the
Academy members for making the song a
winner
thank you
like James I'm a stranger to all this
but I'd like to thank James Griffin and
Fred Carlin and everyone involved thank
you I've really enjoyed very much
working with the director sy Howard who
directed lovers and other strangers v I
felt the warmth and humanity that that
he captured on screen was a tremendous
inspiration to me and I want to thank
him very much I also would like to thank
two other very special friends Karen and
Richard carpenter for their very moving
interpretation of for all we know thanks
to everybody they'd be seeing thank you